my name is brent decessor i'm one half
of wd detailing and today we're going to
be cleaning a 1978 sterling nova that
sat in a barn since 1985.
so sterling nova is a kit car which is
on a volkswagen beetle chassis and
engine
and it's really unique because of the
way it looks and the way that the top
opens
there's no doors on this car the way
that you get in and out is literally by
the whole top
lifting up
we had to take the top off of this car
because it actually couldn't hold its
own weight up and we didn't want to risk
it falling on one of us
as soon as we took the top off of the
car we found this mouse nest right on
the back side of the dash
it was made out of insulation or carpet
or parts from the seats any random
fibers that they can find in the car
they'll take and make a nest out of then
we sanitize the area afterwards with
tri-clean which is a cleaner that will
kill all the bacteria
cars attract mice because they know that
it's a dark space and when these cars
sit in a barn and nobody's touching them
for 30 plus 40 plus years they're not
going to be bothered so they're going to
take advantage of that and then after
that we were able to take the seats out
and really get in there and clean
everything we found that these carpets
were completely disintegrated and
they're definitely gonna have to replace
them and we actually haven't really seen
carpets this bad before
so if i had to make an assumption on why
this happened
it's a combination of them sitting over
time and the mice getting into them and
eating them up
and under the carpet as soon as we
pulled it out i looked down and found a
nice surprise of a dead mouse
we disposed of it off camera but we just
had to pick it up with our gloves and
toss it in the garbage can
there's no nice way to throw away at
that mouse
we started vacuuming the floor pans and
then we sanitize them again with our
tri-clean
and then we used our steamer behind it
to kill anything else
and then we wiped it all away with
microfiber towels
so this dashboard was covered in dust
completely and at this point we're still
using tri-clean to clean the interior
because we want to disinfect everything
we knew that this car isn't going to be
started for quite a while because it
doesn't run and it needs a lot of repair
work so if cleaner gets inside the
buttons or inside of the switches it's
not going to be the end of the world
because it'll definitely dry up before
there's any kind of electricity running
through this car
[Music]
so if you want to get a barn find a good
way is searching on facebook marketplace
the people that we work with
specifically search for these cars and
then they bring them to us because they
sat for so long
a lot of it's word of mouth
so for these seats they were covered in
anything that the mice could put on them
so the first thing that we do is vacuum
them and then we'll go ahead and extract
them so we use our extractor soap and
then we'll use our drill brush to
agitate the soap and really work it into
those fibers and then we'll use our
extractor which shoots hot water into
the fibers and also sucks it away at the
same time so it's a vacuum but it's a
vacuum with water
the exterior this car was covered in
dust from front to back and then there
was some wood chips and other stuff
in the headlight crevice which
i'm pretty sure on this kit they're
supposed to be a headlight cover but for
some reason they were missing on this
specific car
and here we're vacuuming out some of the
jams which we like to do before we
pressure wash off the car because if
there's any wood chips or anything it
might scratch the paint
so on the wheels they were covered with
some sort of green substance which i
don't know if it was mold or not and to
clean this tire we'll go ahead and
pressure wash everything off of it first
and then we'll use our pns brake buster
on the tire and the rim
and then we'll use an assortment of
brushes usually soft bristle brushes and
a tire brush and then we'll pressure
wash it all away
the paint on this car was in pretty good
condition the only thing that we noticed
was deteriorating was the black paint
so we're spraying on this car is a paint
safe degreaser so we can loosen up all
that dirt before we pressure wash it
away and what that's going to do is
minimize any kind of swirl marks or
scratches
paint chips can be damaging to a car
only because it can cause rust to form
if there's metal underneath where the
paint was but there was no rust on this
body at all because it's made out of
fiberglass
so we're starting to film the car here
using our pressure washer and foam
cannon and this is the part that a lot
of people find the most satisfying in
the whole process
and there's two reasons why people use
foam cannons the first one is as a
pre-soak
so they can loosen up all the dirt
that's on the surface of the car but
also instead of just putting soap in a
bucket it helps you put soap over the
entire car which makes the process safer
for the paint and easier
and after foaming the car we'll use
microfiber mitts on the entire car to
wash it down
and now we're using our rupes buffer to
take any of the oxidation off the top
layer of the paint
which will make it a lot shinier less
dull
and give it that overall wow factor at
the end so this is just like a paint
correction when it came to the black
paint we didn't even polish it at all
because it was starting to come off of
the car
and we didn't want to ruin or take away
any of that paint that was already there
there wasn't too much that we could
personally do it's something that would
have to either be redone or just left as
is
and after the whole car is cleaned and
we're ready to do the finishing touches
we'll do a tire shine and as that dries
it leaves the tires looking nice and
matte black and it just gives it that
overall wow factor for the customer
and the absolute last thing we'll do is
spray a ceramic sealant over the entire
car it'll protect the paint just a
little bit but it also give it a nice
shine and just complete the detail
that's it
i was super happy with the way that this
car turned out i actually personally
want to buy it myself we'll see how that
goes in the near future when it's done
being fixed up
when it comes to cleaning barn finds if
i can give any advice it's just to take
your time and really do your research
that way you don't make any super
detrimental mistakes because the last
thing you want to do is find something
that has original paint or an original
interior and damage it but also have fun
with the process
mice when they get in cars they they
freaking destroy them if they have
enough time they'll chew your cables out
eat your carpets they'll eat your seats
from the inside out they will absolutely
destroy your car